in high school I had a bunch of
vocabulary homework and one night I was
studying with my dad and I realized I
could build a program that would do the
same thing that my dad was doing but
much faster I built it and for the next
test I got 100% I kept working on it and
eventually released it
Quizlet is a platform for people to
study anything and everything whether
they're an eighth grader running Romeo
and Juliet whether they're in biology
class they can input the curriculum they
want on Quizlet and we give flashcards
and different games and tools that help
keep track of what you know and don't
know from the first month we had about
500 users and now we have 22 million
uniques a month we're now reaching a
quarter of all us high school students
every month lo and behold Google Play
for education comes about and now we're
one of the first apps that teachers go
to when they think I want to use some
study tools in my classroom our business
has been enabled by this base layer that
Google has set up that's really exciting
a Google Play Store lets you iterate
really quickly with getting updates out
to users there's a beta program so we
can get feedback find crashes and
iterate on our product before launching
it to everyone Google Play for education
is really exciting to us because it's a
core distribution platform that students
and especially teachers can easily get
Quizlet on to lots of kids devices at
the same time can be so cool to see how
Quizlet improves and especially how
close it's going to improve on Android
devices lots of teenagers say that
before they use Quizlet they just
couldn't figure out how to study and
this was the thing that tipped them into
being able to get a really great
education